[Music]
when people started seeing the 2u
together
you know
all of a sudden everyone do your name
how has that affected your
relationship the two of you i guess i've
never really dealt with that obviously
chris dealt with her relationships being
in the public eye before i've dealt a
little bit with it in australia but
definitely not over here in the united
states which like huge everything's
still pretty chill it's only like i
google myself then like i'll see random
articles popping up but i don't really
do that so
i don't know it's been pretty chill to
be honest hasn't been too chaotic
identifying as non-binary g-flip made an
effort to be more inclusive when hiring
crew for their video
get me out of here you have like 80
percent clear people who are making your
video how important was it for you to be
able to give people the platform to work
in the industry and make things that
they love yeah it's definitely super
important and there was such a great
supportive and amazing team that worked
on get me out of here it was really cool
to be on that set and it was just so
comfortable and easy and such a fun day
and that music video turned out great
and we're all really stoked about it
what do you attribute your natural
ability to just like glaze ahead
be yourself
you look like you're having the best
time in the world i'm just stoked to be
doing this for a living like this is a
dream as a kid and every day i wake up
and i'm like is this actually happening
like
is this real
so yeah man i'm just like
it's the coolest thing ever and i'll
never take it for granted